I actually think most women taking 3
days off of social media would be crazy
to them I I think that's the norm not
the exception so how do these women go
from getting all of this attention to
being monogamous I I don't think it's
likely I think it's mostly impossible I
think the modern relationship is going
to be the best ones are the woman is
sexually exclusive but she will still
receive attention and validation from
other men you will still see women and
and really I don't even want to say you
still see it you see it now I I see
wives and mothers and that that's why I
started the hash em challenge because I
these conservative influencers would
talk about how conservative they are yet
they would be posting super sexual
pictures while married I I just couldn't
even believe it